have been elected to the 45-member
strong shura council the rest will be
appointed by the country's emir no women
were elected to the council despite 27
candidates running in the polls voter
turnout was 63.5 percent jamal
reports from doha
for the first time in their lives
qataris have chosen who will represent
them when it comes to drafting the
country's laws and monitoring the
government's performance
on saturday thousands across the small
peninsula took to one of 30 different
polling stations in the nation's first
ever legislative elections
now as you know it's female that we call
the man and this is a proudest like
as a woman they can have a chance to
choose
for us this is a democratic ceremony
that's new and modern for qatar and
everyone is participating in this
council that's important for the citizen
and the state
until now the shora council has been an
advisory body appointed solely by the
emir with limited powers however in its
new form two-thirds of it is elected by
the people and it will have the ability
to draft laws approve or reject budgets
and even question and sack ministers
after the 2017 the qatar blockade crisis
uh i believe uh that the political
maturity among the qatari people being
raised very very carefully and very uh
mature to the extent that it's not about
that qatar people are you know asking
for sasha election even though we've
been listening to some voices from the
elite people however it's more about top
bottom approach that being supported and
initiated by by the the the political
leadership
unlike other countries in the region
that have witnessed mass protests and
uprisings demanding a change in
governance the move towards greater
representation on qatar has been driven
by the leadership
despite this top down drive to a more
inclusive political system the turnout
in saturday's polls indicate that many
in qatar are in favor of having a
greater say
with no political parties in the gulf
state the new legislators are expected
to come under greater individual
scrutiny issues such as labor law
reforms economic policy and who gets to
take part in future elections will be
some of the defining topics for when the
shorter council gets to work
some qataris have already complained
about being left out of the electoral
process
for many qataris these shura elections
are not simply about the results with
people now given a say as to who
represents them everyone is a winner
widening participation and empowering
different sections of society
underscores qatar's branding as a
country that is often positioned itself
differently to its neighbors when it
comes to political pluralism and freedom
of expression